les yvelines troisième département d'île
de france concernant le nombre de
médecins le territoire yvelinois compte
2068 médecin 2008 généralistes selon les
chiffres de l'agencé régionale de santé
l'âge moyen est de 53 59 ans et pour les
spécialistes la moyenne atteint 64 5 ans
avec un impact sur l'évolution entre
2011 et 2017 l'écart entre les
praticiens entrants et sortants
s'accroît en six ans les yvelines ont
perdu 109 généraliste et 154
spécialistes une situation expliquée par
la non compensation des départs à la
retraite
les médecins ne peuvent plus répondre à
la demande de la population sachant
qu'en même temps que le déficit
s'accroît c'est en dans les yvelines de
la population augmenter et donc c'est
pour ça qu'on se retrouve avec des
grosses difficultés de prise en charge
des patients
la rs classe des communes en deux
catégories en fonction du nombre de
médecins par habitant
les ips zone d'intervention prioritaire
et les zac zone d'action complémentaires
dans les yvelines et communes rurales
sont principalement classé en zip
actuellement 178 médecins exercent sur
saint quentin en yvelines 132 médecins
généralistes et 46 médecins spécialistes
sur les douze communes 8 sont concernés
par le classement de la rs notamment les
clayes-sous-bois trappe et la verrière
classé en zone d'intervention
prioritaire
les villes qui se sont le plus
industrialisés ont vu d'abord dans les
années 60-70 s'installer les médecins et
ceux qui sont installés dans les années
1970 sont en train de partir et après
les nouvelles communes day type
guyancourt elancourt les médecins sont
arrivés plus tard se sont installés plus
tard et donc partiront plus tard donc le
déficit qui apparaît actuellement il est
surtout sur ces communes où
l'installation s'est faite dans les
années 70 classés en zip ou en sac les
communes peuvent bénéficier des aides
pour attirer des médecins et les
praticiens s'installant dans ces zones
disposent d'accompagnement c'est d'abord
le contrat d' aides à l'installation des
médecins ce qu'on appelle le kaïm qu'il
a est accessible dans les iep
et pour les médecins qui s'installent en
première installation qui permet un
financement à hauteur de 50 mille euros
c'est le contrat de praticiens
territoriale de médecine générale
le pt mg qui hélas est accessible autant
dans les zac que dans les iep ans et qui
permet de garantir un revenu brut
mensuel de 6900 euros
d'autres mesures peuvent être aussi
envisagées le gouvernement a engagé une
réforme sur le sujet
ma santé 2022